it looks like a pharmaceutical lab and
in a sense it is Swiss engineers
perfecting the dose of caffeine in your
morning cup of Starbucks thermo plans
goal allow untrained baristas to concoct
your favorite milky coffee with the
press of a button even if they grew up
drinking tea all these machines are
destined for China the idea is to get
them hooked on foamy frothy drinks but
first they need to be tested some a
hundred times let's give it a go if you
want to predict how quickly Starbucks
will grow in Asia you may want to put
this company in a small Swiss village
where they make all of Starbucks
cappuccino machines under surveillance
17 years ago at an Oklahoma where 20
employees and Starbucks at that time
were 20,000 employees right now we are
220 and Starbucks is more than 200,000
so growing together wages are high in
Switzerland but the workers are skilled
there's Swiss efficiency on the assembly
line I'm clearly not qualified to use
this but if I could there may be one
limit to thermal plants and Starbucks
growth in China funny tummies
there is lactose intolerance yes that's
right but the growth of the coffee
industry is proving that they like to
drink this milk based babbitt's for
Starbucks and of course other customers